- Hey, Nawin.
Möchtest du etwas essen?
- Was gibt es denn?
- Sushi, Pizza, Salat.
- Okay.
- Nico, was möchtest du essen?
- Ich möchte eine Pizza, bitte.
- Hier, das ist die Speisekarte
von unserem Lieblingsitaliener.
- Danke.
- Nico,
das ist Nawin.
Nawin, Nico.
- Hallo! Ich bin Nico.
- Nico?
Bist du der Nico aus dem Radio?
- Ja, Nico war im Radio.
- Du suchst deine Tasche!
- Ja.
- Leute, die Speisekarte.
Was nehmt ihr?
- Ich möchte eine Pizza
mit Thunfisch.
- Sehr gut. Ich nehme auch
eine Pizza mit Salami.
Und Nico, möchtest du
eine Pizza mit Thunfisch,
eine mit Salami oder eine
mit Tomate Mozzarella?
- Ich nehme eine
Pizza mit Salami, bitte.
- Gut. Und ich nehm' wie immer
meine Pizza Hawaii ohne Schinken.
- Pizza Hawaii?
- Das ist eine Pizza
mit Ananas und Schinken.
Nina liebt Ananas,
sie ist aber Vegetarierin
und deshalb nimmt sie die Pizza
jedes Mal ohne Schinken.
- So und ich bestelle.
Wo ist mein Handy?
Danke!
Ach, eine Nachricht auf Book!
- Das Foto?